hi in this video I will talk about
dendritic cells now dendritic cells are
critical for initiation of the immune
response they are both part of innate
immunity and they also work like a
bridge between innate and adaptive
immunity their name is dendritic cell
because of their long branches which are
very similar that of the dendrites of a
neuron that's why their name is
dendritic cell now dendritic cell was
discovered by Ralph Steinman around
1970s and for that he got a Nobel Prize
at 2011 question is where does these
dendritic cells come from dendritic cell
is developed from Haider my progenitor
or it is developed from myeloid
progenitor in the bone marrow so both of
that progenitors can potentially give
rise to ten criticsm now let's try to
understand the function of the dendritic
cell we very easy examples for example
think of a country it's foreign
is that enough secured by fences such
that intruders cannot come in and they
are bordered patrolling pulleys which is
always patrolling near the border to
look for intruders similarly several
barriers of our body
for example the skin just underneath the
skin they are patrolling police like
cells for example dendritic cell and
macrophages which are always patrolling
near the boundaries of the skin and
looking for potential pathogen now let's
say in a country there is a invasion of
a terrorist from the border and he did a
blunder in the border and when the
patrolling police come there patrolling
police can see several trails for
example in
magazines bullet chills etc now in our
skin that said there is invasion of a
pathogen by a physical injury with a
rusty nail some pathogens associated
with that get inside to our skin and as
a result our patrolling police of our
immune system or dendritic cell would go
and inspect the pathogen and try to kill
the pathogen so one option is dendritic
cell recognize the pathogen by specific
receptor on their surface called
toll-like receptors or TLRs so if you
don't know what is what are TLRs you
should watch the video on the end screen
I have a detailed discussion on T iners
and the signaling mechanism by which
dendritic cell or macrophages can
recognized pathogen associated molecular
patterns so the bacteria or the pathogen
or some molecular signatures of the
pathogen could be recognized by the
dendritic cell by these specialized
receptors called TLR
the DLR sends signal into the nucleus
which I ultimately produce cytokines in
red so the cytokines are sort of alarms
which would which would kind of alarm
the other cells of the vicinity to come
to the place of injury now for example
in this picture you can see that the
dendritic cell has secreted a lot of
cytokines that attract other dendritic
cell and macrophage to the injury site
so that would help so those are back up
for these dendritic cell that would help
to combat the pathogen efficiently the
second option is the dendritic cell
might kill one of the pathogen by
phagocytosis again and then chill down
and displaying its peptide on the
surface of the dendritic cell but
dendritic cell or petroleum police they
don't have that power to kill all the
pathogens that are invading from the
boundary so dendritic cell
we'll do something as following our
patrolling police officer is also not
that wealthy and he cannot come back
whole terrorist force so he would go and
conveyed his news of terrorist invasion
in the border to a army base where there
are specialized divisions of army which
can which are ready to combat these
terrorist force similarly our dendritic
cell would go to the lymph node which is
sort of the army pace of the immune
system where P cell and t-cell recite
dendritic cell would display their
pathogen on to a class 2 MHC to a t-cell
t-cell would also help to growth and
development of several pieces and it
will ultimately give rise to specific
antibody producing plasma cells so if
you liked my video give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you